henri ménudier bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors on parle d'un revers de
débâcle 1 ce matin pour angela merkel
son parti a fait le pire c'est le pire
score de son histoire lors de ces deux
scrutins régionaux comment est-ce qu'on
peut le comprendre
d'abord il faut savoir que ce sens deux
régions se trouvent en allemagne de
l'ouest
quand toujours été des places fortes de
laquelle des chrétiens démocrates où il
entend gouverner
parfois même avec des majorités absolues
donc se retrouver avec des résultats
aussi faibles
naturellement est apprêtée comme une
commune catastrophe alors une
catastrophe qui serait due à quoi on rit
ménudier comment l'expliquer il y avait
les effets de la crise sanitaire ou
naturellement la politique du
gouvernement est très discutée voir
contester comme ça se passe aussi en
france et puis à cela s'est ajoutée et
le problème de la corruption
on a en effet découvert que plusieurs
députés mais servi d'intermédiaire entre
les entreprises et les trains régional
ou fédéral pour revendre des mains des
masques ou d'autres produits et qu'en
même temps ils ont empoché et des sommes
importantes
le aurait touché 600 mille euros un
autre 250000 euros
alors on pourrait facilement imaginer
que dans le climat actuel
quand cela a été découvert eh bien ça
fait quand même un énorme scandale et
les allemands n'aiment pas du tout ce
que les hommes politiques se rendent
coupables de corruption
on avait eu un scandale semblables qui
avait coûté et le présidence d'honneur
de la cd ou avec helmut kohl
lorsqu'on avait découvert c'était en
1998 ce qu'on avait découvert qu'il
avait et qu'ils recevaient de l'argent
de la part des 15 entreprises et que cet
argent n'était pas déclarée et qu'il
administrait lui-même et est ce que
c'est le résultat de ces deux élections
finalement est un bon indicateur avant à
six mois
des élections législatives fédérales
pour savoir qui succédera au gué la
merkel
j'ai simplement mauvais pour la peau là
dessus des ou pas ce que je fais aussi
mauvais score dans des länder qui en
principe lui sont acquis il a longtemps
régné ces échappements mauvais cela dit
il peut y avoir des fluctuations
il faut pas oublier qu'en encore au mois
de janvier
la vidéo était donnée largement gagnante
de ces élections
venez en tête dans tous les sondages
mais il ya la fatigue qui est liée à la
crise la crise sanitaire
et puis les cas de les cas de corruption
dont il reste encore quelques mois il y
aura au moins de joie je crois le 6 juin
encore une élection régionale en
allemagne d'un allemagne de l'est et le
26 septembre il y aura les élections les
élections fédérales
donc le problème maintenant pour le cd
ou pour les chrétiens démocrates en
allemagne c'est de choisir le candidat
le candidat chrétien démocrate à la
chancellerie
alors justement c'est une question
compliquée est ce qu'il ya des
personnalités qui se détache
il ya que deux personnalités qui
viennent actuellement en ligne de compte
il ya le nouveau président de la cds aux
messieurs armes ils l'achètent qui elle
était très mal élu récemment le
président d'accéder aux donc c'est pas
si en plus ce n'est pas en mesure
d'attirer les électeurs
vous voyez que ce n'est pas une très
bonne perspective et puis à son
concurrent le plus sérieux et qui est le
monsieur thunder le chef du gouvernement
régional de la bavière est actuellement
très populaire aussi populaire que
madame merkel mais je trouve que son
problème ce qu'il est depuis peu depuis
quelques années seulement chef du
gouvernement régional de la bavière et
il n'a pas encore c'est véritablement
chez preuvre bien qu'il ait acquérir une
certaine autorité surtout en connais
très mal ses positions sur les questions
sur lesquelles international donc et par
ailleurs les bavarois lorsqu'ils ont été
candidats à la chancellerie n'ont jamais
eu beaucoup de chance sur le plan sur le
plan électoral
vous voyez que la situation pour les
chrétiens démocrates
et plutôt un chéque troubles
actuellement merci beaucoup henry
minutier pour cet éclairage le rappelle
vous êtes professeur honoraire à la
sorbonne et spécialiste de l'allemagne